I know I stand on the way between you
and and and the party after that so I'm
going to try to be entertaining anyway I
spoke with Tomas a long time ago saying
this conference is a great place to
actually meet the web developers and we
wanted to interact a little bit more and
let you know about all the web evolve
right so I invited one of my mentor
Danielle Burnett that has been an
invited expert in a chairman for a long
time next slide then and what we really
want to speak about today is free
question right now was the web aney
internet created next slide Oh does it
keep evolving well you saw a lot of
example yesterday and today I SWAT least
22 presentation today speaking about
HTTP to that was created in something
called IETF and all the working group
and so on and so forth so how does it
work exactly you know can you not only
benefit from it but create the next
version of the web html5 HTML 6 next
slide and even better how can you
actually take the control and go on the
driver's seat and say I want to be part
of HTML 6 I have some very very good
idea and I don't want that to be on the
framework I want it to be the next the
next web I want to make a difference i
want to change the word and i want it
better than flappy bird to write so
that's basically the free question we're
going to try to to address during the
presentation today we using a web RTC
technology right now which is part of
html5 to screen do slides directly from
atlanta and danielle is going to join us
from there directly next slide that's
what i'm saying next slide all the time
he has a control so we are we my name is
unpronounceable so everybody call me dr.
alex and i'm an invited expert
as ietf w3c and a few other standard
committee in the word with a speciality
on web RTC and what makes me a little
bit different is I'm the only one from
Southeast Asia attending these meetings
and I'm based in Singapore so I wanted
to give back a little bit to the
southeast asia and Singapore community
and now i will let dan introduced
himself and we don't have audio wait
then we don't hear you so it's
supposedly plugged in can someone from
the technical staff give us a hand here
good I look I got that here
go on diamond try again hi everyone you
know yet here's something we hear from
the back but not the beauty of
technology somebody running can you say
again yes we can hear him from the back
but it doesn't seem to be connected to
the speakers Cooper
that's
yeah this one so you're already on the
right one then do not sing but please
say something so they can taste the Sun
yes testing all right fantastic all
right it happens all the time when the
streaming is the local microphone does
is so there's a lot of things that
happen in a streaming of media audio and
video and most of the time the problem
is between the keyboard and the seat but
not always all right done all yours okay
yes so hi everyone yes so I've been
involved with w3c and IETF two
organizations I'm going to be talking
about today for for many years I started
in 99 and w3c and 2001 in ITF I've been
an editor of many specifications in w3c
currently one of the primary editors of
the WebRTC specification and and some
other other work going on right now but
let's go ahead and move right on into
the presentation okay so the first thing
I wanted to talk about is something that
probably many of you know but possibly
not all of you people often use the term
web the terms web and Internet done
interchangeably yes we do not have the
slide on screen you did not have the
slides please can you scream you or can
you share you yes yes
did not share them this time not yet
yeah I saw myself for a minute that was
frightening can you please focus on the
slides okay can you see them now perfect
okay here we go alright so the web is
not the internet right the internet is
the plumbing it's all the stuff at the
low level that actually controls how
information flows from one place to
another so it's the plumbing HTTP https
email dns the internet protocol itself
of course tcp UDP all of these are
internet level protocols the web is
about content primarily HTML I'll talk
more about that in a minute Alex do you
want to say something about the Rhine
slightly and we did the slide with two
levels in mind the global level right so
you guys get the global process and
everything and then in a different color
things that can be more of interest to
the local people or the Asian community
so the government of Singapore recognize
the difference between internet and the
web and has created two different
agencies to actually deal with that so I
da is the one taking care of the
internet and the infrastructure
including big data for smart nation in
Singapore and MDA is going to be the
media development authority that take
care about the content and blocking some
internet site if they disagree with the
content and everything that is related
to multimedia application so when you
guys deal with that with the local
government keep that in mind even though
recently I think they fuse the two
agencies okay
so I want to just give very brief
history of internet and web so the
internet was started as as many of you
know probably as a US government Defense
Department project to connect
universities and the US government and
then it actually it grew rather rapidly
to be a set of a collection of different
networks and they quickly realized that
there was a need for a better way to
connect them together and that way was
the Internet Protocol right so the one
that connects different networks so even
though today we think of the Internet as
one way basically a way for any computer
to directly connect to any other
computer it originally started as just a
way to connect different local networks
and actually that is what the internet
is today despite our attempts to pretend
otherwise with network address
translators and so on of course ipv6
promises the hope that we can still I
guess we can go back to the original or
go go to a notion where you can connect
directly from one machine to another but
we probably will end up keeping gnats
and firewalls for all the wonderful
policy reasons that we know about today
so that's the internet it wasn't
actually until a good bit later that Tim
berners-lee a researcher at CERN in
Switzerland created HTTP the hypertext
Transfer Protocol and HTML the hypertext
markup language what Tim realized he was
actually working with other researchers
and realized that at the time there were
different protocols for getting
different
of information ftp archie gopher these
were all different protocols for getting
information at the time and it was it
was a nuisance having to remember which
protocol you were using when really as
an end user all you cared about was
being able to access information and
that was stored somewhere other than on
your machine so by creating this
standard protocol for fetching resources
and then creating a language HTML that
made it very easy to link to and
reference resources and other places he
dramatically simplified the use of the
internet so that's I think the main
reason why people in general refer to
these two as the same thing today even
though they're not and that's because of
what Tim berners-lee did now Tim
berners-lee did go on also to create the
world wide web consortium which I'll
talk about in a moment so this is where
the internet and the web came from but I
guess a good question now is where does
it come from today what happens when
changes need to be made and the answer
is all of us we are the ones who make
the internet we are the ones who make
the web as you know the internet today
is not controlled by any one entity any
one organization there are organizations
that have strong influence over some of
the architecture of the Internet but it
is all of the devices all of the
individual networks that exist around
the world that make up the internet and
it is all of the content that all of us
create and all of you in particular that
is the that is the web but of course all
of this works because of standards that
exist and it is the standards bodies for
the internet and the web that
define the protocols and the floor mats
that make things actually work so one
interesting question something surprises
many people is how the standards
actually get enforced and the truth is
they're they're not I'm going to be
talking about the organizations involved
in just a moment but these organizations
are are not official in the sense that
that governmental bodies drive them or
or support them actually the standards
for the internet and the web are just
documents created by smart people and
people use them because they're good
they're good quality I'm going so really
i'm going to interject here than to
really rebound on that there is no
internet police there is no web police
either right and the fact the thing is
the people that actually create the web
are people that are using it so they
have a tendency of doing the right thing
and i think again if I I have to give an
example that you saw today is HTTP to
HTTPS really better than HTTP right is
really going to address a pain point you
have today it's faster it's easier to
use it has a lot of things that were
learned from HTTP and that evolved into
something something better and adapt to
the current tool but for that to be
possible right we need to have feedback
from the people that actually use the
tool so we get back to that later but we
need to know what the pain point hard
today with the current technology to
make the next better one right and
you're not going to use them because
they exist right they are a lot of RFC
so specifications are sleeping dormant
because nobody really use them and that
we pushed by the industry and there
others like HTTP to that really really
address abandon are going to be used and
half of the people including done in
myself that go to those committees on
not paid to do so which is going there
to do the right thing and because they
believe in into making the web a better
place with you feedback right the news
rapportage exactly exactly there's
there's no one who actually makes us do
it of course there are as Alex said
probably about half the people who are
there are there not because they have a
specific company position to represent
but they're there because they feel
strongly about the the protocols and the
format's doing the right thing this is
really significant okay there are many
other skin standards organizations in
the world probably the most well-known
ones in the tech space are the ITU gsm a
3gpp etc and these organizations create
very good and useful standards primarily
for the telephony and mobile telephony
industries but for the internet and the
web there there is no governmental
supported it really is just a group of
nerds they get together and and try to
make the right thing happen and so some
people actually join some company
because of that beliefs everybody i know
that work at mozilla which is a non for
nonprofit organization is participating
to the specification to try to make the
web a better place not because they're
getting paid to do it that's actually
the other way around so that's a really
exciting place to be to be surrounded by
people that are not there because they
paid not there because the company has
an incentive or pushing their technology
in one way or another but really trying
to do the best thing for everybody out
there that's really rewarding for an
individual yeah at the last I ETF
meeting that they just happened recently
I was talking with to first-time
attendees one from Tunisia and one from
Pakistan and both of them
were really amazed mostly at the quality
of the conversations that happen they
were surprised to find that they could
walk into those meetings and be talking
with people directly at a deep technical
level that is exactly what you can
expect organizations like that because
again it is the people who want the
right thing to happen you know what's
going on who will debate what should be
done and definitely if if an idea is bad
you'll hear about it but if an idea is
good people will will listen to it as
well ok so the IETF the internet
Engineering Task Force is the group that
defines the protocols for the internet
and it really is free to participate
there is a cost if you want to attend
the face-to-face meetings and that's
just because it costs money to reserve
the space but keep in mind that the
reason for that is that there is no one
company sponsoring the entire event they
do get corporate sponsors but the core
of the meeting itself is supported by
the fees that people k to attend and
that's only when you attend the
face-to-face meetings actually all of
the work is done or the majority of the
work is done on the mailing list yeah
the remote one seat the remote Pacific
participation to IETF is free there is
no membership fee and everybody
represent only himself right so you
don't represent a company or anything
and really the the idea behind that is
the Internet is free and everybody
should be equal in voicing which we
should go ITF meetings are the only
meetings where you are maybe thirty five
percent of the audience which are
actually students that take the
opportunity you having those meetings
locally to learn from from other people
and to learn how it happens I etfs that
rotation rule where you're going to have
three meetings a year and one meeting
per continent to give everybody almost
equal opportunity to at least one
so you're drawing the meeting and learn
and participate right everything else is
done online for free right at them the
main reason front of these place to face
meetings is to get to meet other people
working in your area and in other areas
so again that's not where the majority
of the work happens but I would
encourage you if you've been
participating on the mailing list for a
while definitely get started on the
mailing list but if you've been
participating for a while on the mailing
list you might want to try attending one
of the meetings just to give you another
example of how hard the IETF tries to
make it easy for any person to
participate there's one one thing that
people do at meetings that seems strange
you to most first-time visitors and that
is when it comes time to vote or get an
idea in in the room how how people feel
about perhaps one approach versus
another approach instead of actually
doing a vote the IETF takes a hum and
that's where they just ask each person
to hum for what their for their choice
and they did that because when they
early on when they had people raised
raised their hands to indicate what they
were interested in they found that if
someone was sitting there let's say
you're a technical person attending and
your boss is also there with you you
might have a different opinion from your
boss and you might be afraid to raise
your hand because you you might not want
your your boss to see that that's your
opinion because it might not be
considered appropriate by your boss but
when when people home it's very hard to
tell where the hums are coming from so
that was actually done specifically to
make it so that you can have your vote
count and have it be anonymous just to
guarantee that you actually get the real
opinions of the people in the room now
again it's only what happens on the
mailing list that's official but
that can be good for getting a general
idea for for which approaches people
prefer now what is the IETF do a guide
TF creates rfcs requests for comments
another funny name basically that's the
end stage process in the IETF is the
request for comment I'm not going to be
talking today primarily about the IETF
process I wanted to to focus more on the
w3c process but Alex maybe you could say
just a little bit about this right the
good news is I told you once every year
you have free meetings right one in
every continent and the last one is
always in Asia and it's been
traditionally in North Asia so far it
was in Beijing the year before it was in
sayville two weeks ago next year is
going to be in Singapore right and
almost fully found it so everybody that
is in Southeast Asia will have something
more local to actually go to and
interact with all the people that create
http/2 and create all the cool
technology that you saw example of today
so that's a great opportunity to
actually go and mingle with people and
ask question it's not every day that you
can actually see it another coffee with
a chief architect of Microsoft edge and
and that kind of people and ask them any
question about not what they did put
why'd they did that today you so a lot
of example of what you can do with HTTP
too but then you don't know why they
make this choice and not another choice
what are the next feature and swans
those guys can answer those question
right so I think it's a great
opportunity and I encourage everybody to
go there next year november and raffle
hotel thank you since this is a
developer conference i want to talk more
about w3c now so the world wide web
consortium is the one that defines HTML
membership is officially by company but
remember participation is free on the
mailing list there is one global
combined meeting a year all the tea
but there are typically weekly calls and
other face-to-face meetings for the
individual groups what w3c as is to
create recommendations so in w3c if you
have an idea you can actually go and
create a community group you need one
member of w3c to support you and then I
met other people beyond that who express
interest in it but with that you can
create a community group no cost to you
mailing list only but it's a great place
to discuss now the moment you want to
actually create a standard you need to
move on to the standards track and for
that you need a officially created
working room I fink then Gabby Tracy I
think people don't stress enough the
wonderful tool the community group is
and I want to give a few example people
in in Japan say a would like to see
about IPTV or we want to see about a
media display web in vehicle in cars
right or in sub when things like that we
don't know yet if it's going to be
interesting we just want to work create
a group and be recognized you can go
ahead and create a community group in a
few weeks you won't be able to make a
standard yet but you can do all the the
preparatory work for standard if you
want to and that allows you to have the
full weight of the w3c behind you and
the full organization with people that
can help you actually prepare organize
go in touch with the industry and so on
and so forth so community group are
extremely cheap to organize their not
limited to any ID that's really a great
introduction for people to have an ID
and would like to learn or explore or to
work with the with the standard
committee and the industry that's
something that can be done in a in the
scope of a school program with the
excellent University we have here in
Singapore I think that's something
that's really underused today and it's
free absolutely and in fact it's what
w3c is encouraging people to start with
w3c is more and more ass
individuals with ideas to start
community groups and then only request a
working group once they've gotten to
where there is very clear clear
agreement on a path to proceed within a
community group so officially I'm not
going to go through this in detail there
are basically two main group stages in
the standards process there's working
draft and then there are various stages
of the recommendation the working draft
stage is when you're working on the
document but at some point you think
your document is complete and now you
need to just demonstrate that it can be
implemented and that's the candidate
recommendation stage so the two main
areas you'll see documents in or the
working draft stage and the candidate
recommendation stage there's a proposed
recommendation stage which is mainly
just like a one month placeholder before
it goes to recommendation to make sure
nothing is is fully broken but just
think of it this way working draft
you're working on it trying to get it
technically complete and candidate
recommendation is when you're trying to
get implementations to demonstrate that
it really does work now unofficially of
course the real process that you're
steadily increasing mindshare and that's
why you begin with a community group you
give people interested agreeing on what
the real problems are and what direction
might be for solution and then in the
standards process you actually begin to
involve wider and you get wider and
wider involvement from other groups
besides yours to make sure that you're
not going to break anything in the
standard and it's very important to
understand that it's only those who
actively participate that matter Alex
had pointed out here in the WebRTC
working group there are 88 people
registered in the working group but only
about 35 show up to the face-to-face
meetings and there really are only 10 to
15 who are actively participating in the
decision so those are the people who are
driving what happens and that's the
that's the important point we want to
make today Google Mozilla Microsoft and
Apple know best right
well no okay they think they do I can
tell you that for every group that I've
been in that those companies have
participated in and that's everyone I
have heard a statement from each one of
them at some point we know what
developers want so trust us if you
disagree at any point then you need to
participate we really need more
developer feedback that's just crucial
in order for this to work out of the 10
to 15 people who are actively working on
web RTC i would say that maybe one isn't
developer is an active developer who
does not work for a company that is that
is implementing the specification it's
actually funny to see those four browser
vendors claiming that they know what the
web developer one more than more than
the developer themself especially when
they disagree with each other right when
multi aware especially when google goes
frontal with with Microsoft and start
saying I know what the devs want no I
know what the devs want and they have
different opinion but at the end of the
day that's that's really that's really
something we worried about by we I mean
the people not working for a browser
vendor is that we lacking enough
feedback from the people that are
actually using the technology and it
should be the first one that matter
which is you and that's really the main
reason why I reach out to Thomas and say
I would like to make that presentation
and tell the guys guys you can you can
actually come and have fun with us and
make a difference we need you right yeah
so Alex go ahead you wanna say yeah I
mean so that's like contributed that the
thing is it's it's actually easy to
follow and contribute right all the
mailing list of free the process is easy
the process used to be very complicated
to actually change the specification the
working draft and so on now we're using
Geeta right so your pull request away
from contributing to HTML 6
Oh long do we have all right 20 where
the editor hi so you have two websites
the w3 org and the IETF dot org to
actually go and document more next slide
but you know most of the evolution is in
the public domain most is free as in
freedom and free as in beer you don't
need to pay and you do whatever you want
and we really need you right so if you
want to make the web a better place for
you just tell us what you need a last
word again ietf is in singapore next
year the government put a lot of money
on the table to host it it's a really
really special one that's the first one
in Southeast Asia that would be awesome
if you guys can go there and if you're
not clear about all you could
participate what you can get from
eternal to make it a wonderful
experience do not is it eight to send
Mia to it
you